man - astra car still can't believe what
happened to her husband almost four
months ago
just like today she was working in the
fields when she got the terrible news my
nephew came to tell me that my husband
had set himself on fire my heart just
stopped I was stunned I could barely
walk by the time I reached him he was
already dead since then she's been in
mourning now she has to care for their
four children by herself she's also been
left with her husband's debts the
family's cotton crops were not bringing
in enough money he'd had to borrow more
and more money just to put food on the
table it's a fate that many families
here share since the start of the year
more than 300 farmers have taken their
own lives faced with drought and crop
failure many see no other way out
Kishore Tiwari has been campaigning for
India's farmers for years during his
visits he hears their stories almost
everyone is in debt simultaneously if
you look at the cost of the livelihood
the cost of the education the cost of
the health care has been increased a lot
so vulnerable 'ti of the farmer and
despair of the farmer has tremendously
increased government has to do more to
support the country's farmers he says
many can no longer afford seeds or
fertilizer the prices are dictated by
large corporations politicians like
Sanjay Ron Todd are struck by the
farmers plight the papers are full of
stories about suicides recently one
farmer hanged himself during a
demonstration in Delhi in
front of TV cameras he too was deep in
debt it's a big crisis this region
wasn't always like this
it was once known as a gold mine but now
we're in the midst of this disaster we
as a government will make every effort
to get out of this situation but we
won't see results for another six months
or more
Monda Shastra cars family finds that
hard to believe the farmers have heard
promises like this before but they say
nothing ever changes